we begin this morning with the changing
story from Saudi Arabia over the death
of Washington Post contributing
columnist Jamal Khashoggi the government
now says he died in a fistfight in the
Saudi consulate in Istanbul Turkey the
announcement came more than two weeks
after khashoggi entered the consulate
and was never seen again
president Trump described the Saudi
announcement as quote a good first step
White House press secretary Sarah
Huckabee sander says the US will closely
follow the investigations into khashoggi
death Holly Williams is in Istanbul with
the latest Holly good morning good
morning it's been 18 days since Jamal
hal-g walked into the Saudi Arabian
consulate just behind me and then
disappeared since then Saudi Arabia has
denied angrily that it abducted harmed
or killed her Shoji calling those
allegations baseless and lies now
suddenly the country is admitting that
her Shoji did die inside that building
but the Saudi version of events leaves
many questions unanswered
and many people unconvinced in the
middle of the night local time Saudi
Arabia finally admitted that Jamal
hisagi had died inside the Saudi
consulate in the words of an official
statement after getting into a fight and
a quarrel that led to his death the
Kingdom expresses its deep regret it
went on 18 Saudi nationals have been
arrested by their government and several
officials have been fired including the
former deputy head of intelligence
thought to have been close to Saudi
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman Saudi
Arabia's explanation has left many
people deeply skeptical her shock she
was a veteran journalist and outspoken
critic of the Saudi government and he
apparently entered the consulate here to
get paperwork he needed to marry his
Turkish fiancee he'd been living in
exile in the US since last year over
fears for his safety but the Saudi
explanation was a good first step
proclaimed president Trump and once
again argued against cancelling
lucrative US military contracts with
Saudi Arabia I would prefer that we
don't use as retribution
canceling 110 billion dollars worth of
work which means 600,000 jobs Turkish
officials speaking anonymously have told
journalists they believe her Shoji was
tortured murdered and dismembered inside
the consulate by a 15 man Saudi team
that left Turkey soon afterwards several
of them reportedly had links to the
Crown Prince
including one who apparently accompanied
the Prince to the US this year the
prince in what some will see as an irony
has now been put in charge of a
committee to reform the country's
Intelligence Agency
there's still no word from the Saudis on
what they did with Jamal hassabis body
Michele Holly Williams in Istanbul good
question thank you